before we move on to other functions
let's also take the partial derivative
of our function here f of X Y or the
partial derivative of Z with respect to
Y so let's now do it in magenta so the
partial derivative of Z with respect to
Y well now we're saying how much does Z
change with respect to Y if X is
constant so this x squared we treat it
as a constant now so the derivative of a
constant with respect to Y is zero so
you ignore it now this XY term the way
we're viewing it now is y is the
variable X is the constant so what is
the derivative of I don't know 5 Y with
respect to Y well it's 5 so the
derivative of XY with respect to Y is
just X and what's the derivative of Y
squared with respect to Y what's just 2y
as you can see it's it's quite symmetric
the partial of Z with respect to X is 2x
plus y the partial of Z with respect to
Y is X plus 2y and that's because this
equation is pretty symmetric the XS and
the Y's kind of do the same thing now we
we picked the point X is equal to point
2 y is equal to point 3 actually let me
erase this because I picked a different
point where I graph then I drew graphed
it ahead of time just to save time so I
don't think I have to do hat include
this anymore so what I did is I picked
the point
I picked at the point X is equal to X is
equal to 0.3 Y is equal to 0.3 and when
X is equal to 0.3 y is equal to 0.3 what
is Z equal to see if point 3 squared is
0.09 point three times point three point
oh nine point three so it's Z is equal
to a point two seven right just
substitute point 3 in for X and Y Z is
equal to 0.2 seven so what is the
partial of Z with respect to X at that
point or we could write F sub X at the
point Y X is equal to 0.3 Y is equal to
0.3 it equals we figured that let's see
2 times 0.3 0.6 plus 0.3
that's equal to 0.9 so the slope in the
X direction at that point
is 0.9 and then if we take the partial
with respect to Y at that same point 0.3
plus 0.6 that's also equal to 0.9 so
let's see if we can visualize this bring
in my graph there we go so this is this
surface once again is the surface of Z
is equal to x squared plus XY plus y
squared and I just this box is kind of
the domain and the x and y dimensions
that I defined kind of I bounded it
because it starts to increase really
fast and then you wouldn't enable seen
you wouldn't be able to see all of this
interesting stuff that happens closer in
but this what I did so this vertical
line I just wanted to show you that when
X is equal to 0.3 y is equal to 0.3 Z is
equal to 0.7 so that just kind of helps
so it shows you that okay that shows
what point we're working with and then
these two lines this is if you think
about it this is the align where Y is
constant
right so this is the slope in the as Z
or as the surface of changes with
respect to X at this point right so this
is the standard line relative to X or
you could kind of view it as if you hold
Y constant here is the tangent line at
that point and then if you hold X
constant here's a tangent line at that
point and as you add like I said in the
last video you can actually have an
infinite tangent lines you have to pick
the direction that you want to go in in
in the XY plane and then you could plot
a tangent line and so that's why we did
partial derivatives to begin with and
actually this is pretty cool we can we
can actually take let me get my mouse we
can actually zoom in on this and zoom in
a little bit more actually want to zoom
in on the part that is interesting let
me translate this I want to so that's
the part that's interesting and now let
me rotate it so you can actually rotate
so this is the tangent this shows that
the the partial of the funk's
with respect to why the slope is 0.9 and
this line shows that the partial of the
slope or the partial of the function
sorry the partial of Z or the partial of
the function with respect to X is 0.9 at
this point at the point X is 0.3
y is 0.3 right X is 0.3 y is 0.3
z is equal to 0.2 7 and we can rotate it
just to get more intuition it I think
it's the the graphing thing looks a
little bit funny sometimes but you see
that both of those lines are tangent at
that point and in fact two lines define
a plane and the plane that's defined by
those two lines or any of the two
tangent lines to that point defines a
tangent plane to the surface so a
surface does have only one tangent plane
but within a tangent plane there an
infinite number of tangent lines well
anyway that's the fun with graphing now
let's just chug through a bunch of
partial derivative problems just so that
you get used to the mathematics on it so
delete that let's do something that
might confuse you just so you see how to
do them let's say that f of X Y and I'm
confining it to three dimensions
although we can do it more actually
maybe I'll do it in more dimensions now
that we're not going to try to visualize
it let's say it's X sine of X cosine of
Y aha so let's take the partial of F
with respect to X this is still going to
be a function of x and y so we treat Y
like a constant so if cosine of a
constant this is just going to be a
constant so we can almost ignore that we
could put that out front we could say
that it's going to be cosine of Y times
the derivative of this with respect to X
so you could say cosine of Y it's just a
number it could be this cosine of Y I
could just be I don't know 5 or PI or
whatever cosine of Y and then because
when you take the derivative the
constant just comes out of the
derivative and then we could take the
derivative of the X's so the derivative
of the first term with respect to X well
that's just 1 times the second
expression so it's sine of X
I'm just doing the product rule here
plus the derivative of the second
expression that's cosine of X cosine of
X cosine of X is the derivative of the
second expression times the first
expression times X so if we wanted to
expand it all out the partial of F with
respect to X just a function of x and y
it equals sine of X cosine of y plus
let's put this X out front just so
change the order X cosine of X cosine of
Y not too difficult you just have to
realize that anything with the Y is a
constant so let's let's reverse it list
will not reverse it let's take the
partial now in the Y direction how much
does F change in the Y direction if we
hold X constant so the partial of F with
respect to Y is still a function of x
and y so the derivative in that
direction is a function of F and x and y
so now X is a constant so this actually
becomes pretty straightforward this
whole X sine of X if X is some number
five this is just a constant so we can
just write that out front so that's just
X sine of X it's just a I know it's hard
for you to to get your to get used to
saying that oh X sine of X that's just a
constant number because you're so used
to taking the derivative with respect to
X and that's the hardest part about
doing these partial derivatives but
anyway this is just a constant term and
now we just take the derivative of this
with respect to Y the derivative of
cosine of Y with respect to Y is minus
sine of Y I'll do that in yellow minus
sine of Y I just wanted to put the minus
out front minus sine of Y there you have
it let's do another one and actually I'm
going to add more variables just to just
let's say that I don't know just so you
get used to the different notation X is
equal to a squared times I don't know a
squared times
B to the third times C to the 1/2 power
now what is the partial derivative of X
with respect to a well everything else
is just a constant what's the partial of
of a squared with respect to a well it's
2a so it'll just be 2a times the
constants times B to the third C to the
one half I can actually get rid of my
parenthesis there what's the partial
derivative with respect to B oh sorry
what's the partial of X with respect to
B well now a squared + C to the one half
are just constant so we could just write
that a squared C to the one half and now
we just take the derivative with respect
to B well that's 3b squared times 3b
squared if I just want to rearrange it
that's 3a squared B squared C to the one
half our not too difficult you just have
to keep in mind what's constant and
what's not and then finally the partial
of X with respect to C a squared B to
the third those are both constants a
squared B to the third time's the
derivative of this with respect to C 1/2
C to the minus 1/2 or we could rewrite
this as 1 a squared B to the third over
2 square roots of C just a little bit of
algebraic manipulation anyway I will see
you in the next video